[Music]
when someone actually shifts their
mindset from a negative to a positive
around aging they gain seven and a half
years of additional life which is more
additional life than if they actually
stopped smoking at 50 or started
exercising at 50 wow so just the mindset
shift so what I you know what I've tried
to do in the last few years is to really
focus on a pro-aging message we're aging
and growing at the same time we don't
talk about old growth uh humans like we
do old growth redwoods the reality is we
are growing our whole lives it's just
we're moving from the playing field of
the body to the playing field of the
Soul or the heart or the cultural
intellect or the relational playing
field of life